Hey youtubers, this is going to be a breakdown
of the Episode 7 Trailer.
Why is this trailer so special.
Because we knew so little about the film going
into it.
This will not be the case with the other sequels.
We’ll already know who most of the characters
are.
The version they’re showing in theaters
is the same one.
So everybody is seeing the same footage.
First thing is the the voice over, I know
it sounds like Benedict Cumberbatch but I
think it’s Max Von Sydow.
We only see a couple of the cast members,
but it’s all about new force sensitive characters
waking up to the force like Luke Skywalker
in Episode 4.
Which is funny because John Boyega here looks
like he’s a stormtrooper on tatooine looking
for this soccer ball droid.
The other side of this, the Dark Jedi at the
end with the modified lightsaber is also probably
one of the younger new cast members but I
don’t think we’ll find out who it is until
we get more footage.
I’ve seen a few of the better rumors about
the arc of the film that I’ll mention at
the end of the video.
But I don’t think this person is the one
doing the voice over.
The modified John Williams Score.
There are special trailers and then there
is this.
Normally trailer music is taken from finished
cuts of the film or from general stock.
Bringing Star Wars back is such a huge deal
they went one step further and had Williams
record special music just for the trailer.
He’s scoring the entire film too, but the
trailer music is just a one off thing.
Disney is probably going to make the audio
track available for download on iTunes eventually.
Here’s a pretty awesome shot inside an imperial
troop transport.
The Stormtrooper helmets look just like the
concept art from earlier this year.
I think the reason they changed the look is
just to make them more practical.
Just more streamlined.
They even updated their blaster rifles here.
Look how shiny.
A lot of this I think is just to make it pop
on screen.
The old ones were a dull black color.
Of course they’re going to be selling these
toys in stores right as the movie comes out.
This is Daisy Ridley, there are also a lot
of rumors about who she’s playing that I’ll
talk about in spoilers.
The X-Wing’s we’ve already seen, they
along with the helmets and uniforms are also
slightly modified like the stormtroopers just
to pop on screen.
The change in the design of the ships is probably
just to account for innovation in the 30 or
so year period since the original trilogy.
I can’t tell which planet this is specifically
but they spent a lot of time on the movie
filming on a lake that was doubling as a very
famous planet we haven’t seen in the movies
yet.
If “It’s a Trap” rings any bells.
But if this clears any questions about the
Empire and the Rebellion up, they’re both
relatively intact.
I don’t know how they’re going to explain
the aftermath of the Battle of Yavin, but
it seems like in this timeline, that was not
the huge blow to the empire that it was in
the expanded universe.
The period after that when the Thrawn Novels
picked up was kind of the begining of the
New Republic Era.
And there won’t be a new republic in the
new trilogy.
It will still be the Empire versus the Rebellion.
We don’t know which planet this is but really
the lightsaber is what we should talk about.
The new Rebels cartoon series intro’d another
highly modified lightsaber with the Inquisitor.
Since Episode 7 is something of a beginning
for new force sensitive characters, I don’t
think we’ll be seeing a ton of dark jedi.
Darth Maul had the double hilt.
So this just looks like the latest Sith affectation.
I think it’s interesting, it definitely
invokes imagery of a traditional broadsword.
And they’ve updated the CG on the energy
blade effects to make them look almost like
trails of fire spitting out.
That’s actually what drew my attention the
most.
It’s makes the lightsaber seem like a much
more violent weapon.
Less like a big glow stick.
Millenium Falcon of course, looking badass
as always.
Notice that they’ve finally repaired the
deflector dish.
The new one isn’t circular.
But the ship, just like the X-Wings is flying
around in the atmosphere of a planet.
It think there’s a couple reasons they included
this shot.
One is because it looks cool against the blue
sky background, but two.
In the classic movies, space battles aren’t
super accurate with the way ships flying around
and fight each other.
Battlestar Galactica, the Ronald D Moore reboot
series tried to do accurate space battles
with the ships manouvering like they actually
would, turning on a dime at really high speeds.
I’m not a physicist, but it’s just things
in space wouldn’t have to turn in big circles
like ships in orbit.
And that looks way cooler, so that’s why
I think they did this in the atmosphere of
a tatooine.
Plus they can add these air trails.
It’s scientifically more accurate and it
looks cooler.
The tie fighters it’s fighting look relatively
the same.
And all the sound effects also sound the same.
If you’ve been watching the new rebels series,
they use all the classic sound foley.
I’m sure they re-recorded a lot of them
over the years but for the most part they’re
all the original sounds.
They’ll probably be showing off the first
full trailer at Celebration next year as a
convention exclusive and then releasing it
online.
I know everyone wants something special for
star wars day on May 4th too.
That’s right around the release of Avengers
2, so Disney will probably take advantage
of that.
Overall the big takeaway is the tactile look
of the universe.
JJ Abrams made it a big deal to do as much
real creature and practical effects as possible.
Don’t be fooled though, there will still
be a shitload of CG.
But because it’s so good now, they can use
CG to make everything look as dirty, lived-in
and steampunky
as
the original trilogy.
One of the earliest comments I heard about
the prequels way way back was how clean everything
looked.
So the visual style of this
film is just a callback to the look of
episode 4 5 and 6.
I don’t expect to get
any official information about the characters
until Celebration, but that’s only a couple
months away.
Disney is keeping as much of the details about
this as close to the vest as possible.
Which I totally don’t mind.
For the first time in forever, we’re going
into a new Star Wars trilogy knowing almost
nothing about the story and the characters.